hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live
webinar gene manipulation in primary
human immune cells successful strategies
and applications for crispr knockout
rnai and beyond i'm susie valdez of
labrutz and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website
and provider of virtual events and
webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by horizon discovery
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit them
at horizondiscovery.com
so let's get started you can pose
questions to the speaker during the
presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left
of your screen labeled ask a question
and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation
to enlarge the slide window click the
arrows at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing
any of this presentation simply
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
and report your problem by typing it
into the ask a question box located on
the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain
your credits i now present today's
speaker brenna brucklocker walder
a manager at the immunology screening
services at horizon
discovery welcome dr rockwalker walder
you may now begin your presentation
hello everyone i'm pleased to present to
you gene modulation in primary human
immune cells
i am from horizon discovery as just
mentioned and
just some information about horizon
discoveries so horizon discovery is a
life science company offering products
and services from
research to therapy and horizons
headquarter is in cambridge uk
and there are regional offices which we
have in the uk
in the us and in japan with the wide
distributor network
and we are very proud to be a world
leader in providing
gene editing services and products which
we provide to our partners at multiple
stages
of the healthcare process so we have a
long heritage in developing gene
modulation tools and
engineered cell models and how we
apply them makes us unique so for
example we provide
gene modulation services of primary
human immune cells
with tools and applications developed
in-house and recently many of our
partners
they are in particular interested in
fighting tumor cell growth
tackling autoimmunity or understanding
virus-related
infections and for these purposes gene
modulated immune cells
are a great choice
in this presentation primary human
immune cells take
center stage so you will learn how to
modulate their gene function
and how to deploy these
gene modulated cells to identify new
targets
or to shed light into the mode of action
or even to use them
as a therapeutic tool it is important to
know that
the strategies and applications
available
to uh they are there to make the most
out of your gene modulation approaches
and to ensure
that they serve your research
so first some considerations about
the immune cells itself so
it is possible to gene modulate
lymphoid and myelin primary human immune
cells with
various different tools ex fibo or
cryo-preserved cells
may be used for gene modulation both is
possible
and as donor to donor variability
is unavoidable the use of biological
replicates
is advisable in addition to
the technical replicas which you should
add as well
depending on the cell type of interest
specific culture conditions are required
in addition it is important to consider
the activation status
and the stimulation of the cells then
the proliferative ability
and the cell yield and also the
transfectability
and the transusability of the cells
you are interested in
so in order to choose the right gene
editing tool
consider the following points what
equipment is available to you for
example
do you have access to an electroporator
and which type of gene modulation do you
want to achieve
is it knocked down or is it knocked out
or should it be transient and
also consider why do you want to
modulate the cells what is your
application you're after
there are several gene modulation tools
available
and in this presentation we will focus
on sh
rna as i rna crispr cas9
and we will also briefly scratch face
editing
so let's first discuss rna interference
rna interference or short rnai
is the process by which the expression
of a target gene
is effectively silenced or knocked down
the silencing mechanism can be induced
by
small interfering rna eyes called as
irnas or hairpin
rnas so short shrnas
as depicted here the sh rna is a
loop structure and that can be processed
into an si rna and the s
a in turn is a double-stranded rna
and both sh rna and s-i-rna
lead through the activity of
several proteins to the degradation of
cellular mrna in a
sequence specific manner and this
mechanism can be used by researchers
to block expression and accumulation of
proteins
leading them to decrease in cell
in its levels in its expression levels
and eventually to knock down
one tool for shrna mediated gene
knocked down is for instance the smart
vector lentiviral shrna
the vector has been designed using
microrna scaffold specific attributes
for high
efficient processing via the endogenous
rnai
pathway and the sh rnas have been the
site
designed using horizons proprietary
algorithm
resulting in highly potent and specific
targeting sequences there's the smart
vector
is also available in an inducible format
and libraries can be also pulled
the seven constitutive promoters and the
two
fluorescence reporters which are also
depicted in in the picture
and will allow you to tailor smart
vector shrna
to specific cells including human
primary immune cells
this is especially useful when
transusing
a cell type for the first time as you
may want to
test the different vectors for their
transduction efficiency as
indicated by the fluorescence image and
by the qpcr data here
we found that the best suited promoter
for human primary cd4 positive t
cells is the mouse cmb promoter
as an example here the
knockdown of row a is shown
and we achieved more than 80 percent of
target silencing
using the mouse cmv raw ash rna
in humans primary cd4 positive t cells
the smart vector shrna is a useful tool
for functional studies screening target
validation
and also for therapeutics for example
celiac is using the smart vector
technology in a phase one
trial for autologous carti candidates
while the shrna approach which we have
just discussed
relies on transfusing cells the
xli rna technology allows delivery
into cells without transfecting reagents
transaction reagents virus or
instrumentation
so the excel si rna is mixed
with a delivery medium that is basically
a rich culture medium formulation
and it can be then simply additive to
two cells whatever you're interested in
for instance you are unstimulated or you
stimulated t
cells the si rna can be added
as a pool or of for si
rnas or it can be also added
individually
and while it is very easy to use
please note that the delivery might be
inhibited by the presence of bsa
in the serum
so we have achieved silencing
silencing effects in unstimulated and
stimulated cells with
good results with the best result in
stimulated t cells in 2 fps during
delivery
so you can after an incubation time you
can also top
up the serum level to give the
cells a bit more serum a bit more
nutrition
to make them happier and here for
example
we have silenced in in stimulated
t cells um they gap the age
um for about um of about 80 percent
which is a very good result and also we
tested different targets which we have
also
um knocked down with a very good
efficiency
so possible applications for this
approach are for instance functional
studies
screenings or we have also used it for
target validation
while we have so far discussed two
approaches
reducing gene expression at the mrna
level
to induce a knock down now we will
discuss
a crispr cas9 approach that permanently
knocks our genes at the dna level
crystal technology allows researchers
to easily alter dna sequences
and modify gene function here
we will only discuss in this webinar and
we will in this presentation we will
only discuss the
knockout mechanism of crispr cas9
and the knockout mechanism is mediated
by
crispr rna tracer rna and the cas9
protein
so the crispr rna or short
abbreviated by crrna is a complementary
sequence
of single-stranded rna and binds the
target dna
and transactivated crispr rna
or short tracer rna and the tracer rna
together with the crispr rna form a
guide rna
that guides the cas9 protein and the
cas9 protein induces then dna double
strand breaks
and to function so that the cas9 protein
can function it requires
a short dna sequence which is called
palm
for the crisper cas9 system
to be applied successfully you require
basically three things you acquired you
require the cells
the cas9 and the guide rna
and there are many reagents available
the cas9
nuclease can be delivered directly as
protein
or mrna it can be expressed
in form of a plasmid or delivered as
lentiviral particles they are available
as in in different formats for instance
with a gfp cassette
or without and the
tfp receptor will allow you to assess
transduction efficiency or to for
example
to enrich yourselves afterwards after
cell sorting
for the guide rna there are also a
variety of reagents that can be used
guide rna can be expressed as a single
guide rna
from particles or from plasmids similar
to the cas9
and they are synthetic crispr rnas with
a
synthetic tracer rna or they are
synthetic single guide rnas
which are also an option there's also
the possibility of using
individual or pooled synthetic guide
rnas
which we will discuss later during this
presentation
and most guide rnas will create
double strand breaks and generate a
knockout but not
all guide rnas cut with equal efficiency
and specificity
knockouts could cause for instance
a silent mutation without a major change
or
they may occur in non-essential regions
of the protein or an unintended target
could be edited
so hence the design of the sgrna is
really crucial
and horizon's edit r algorithm has been
developed specifically to maximize
functionality and the specificity
of the sgs sh
fgrna design so
it is it is a living tool constantly
updated
and rihanna reannotated periodically
using refseq
how to combine the cas9 and the guide
rna formats
depends on the transfectability and
transducebility of cells the cell
stimulation
the cost for scale up and the
application
itself
for example we can combine cas9 protein
with either synthetic crispr
tracer rna or synthetic single
guide rna while the crispr
rna tracer depicted on the left hand
side
is a two-part system they as grna
depicted on the right-hand side
is a one-part system both systems of
nuclease resistance properties and
equivalent experimental costs
and they both also induce
excellent knockouts as you can see here
so he exemplified are knockouts
for using both synthetic guide rna
and also the crispr tracer rnas
we used cd3 and rosa 26.
and it is clearly seen that
the when when there is a knockout
then the fluorescence the median
fluorescence intensity
is decreased which is the case for cells
that have been treated with
the cd3 crispr tracer
and the guide rna cd3 guide rna
and while there's still gene expression
still protein expression of cd3 for the
cells that have been treated with
rosa 26 which has served as a control
here
guide rna can be used individually or
as a pool and here we have evaluated the
performance of both on the left hand
side
individual guides and on the right hand
side
pool guides on the x-axis
the crispr rnase and on the y-axis the
sgrnas
the graphs show that individual
synthetic single guide rnas have
a slight phenotypic knockout advantage
over the crispr tracer rnas
in primary human t cells and
pools of synthetic sgrna
and crispr tracer show a similar
functional knockout performance
and in addition crispr rna pools did not
impact cell viability in non-specific
manner so we achieved very good results
both of them
okay
so next we um we used pools
of crisper tracer rna and um
single guide rna together with cas9
and we titrated the reagents against
each other to balance knowledge
efficiency
and reagent efficiency we
assessed cd3 knockout by flow cytometry
and every rectangle which you can see
here in the heat map
is an average of four technical replicas
on the left side of the heat map the
sgrnas and on the right side of the heat
map
the crisper tracer reagents
the dark blue indicates
high cd3 median fluorescence intensity
meaning there is cb3 expression and the
light blue indicates
low cd3 median fluorescence
meaning there is a knockdown of cd3 so
we identified
not only an optimal ratio of the cas9
and the guide rnas but
indicated by the by the lighter
rectangles but also we
determined the minimum quantities of
reagents required
to achieve a good knockout
in addition we observed that synthetic
guide rnas the single guide rnas induce
editing at a lower concentration
than the crispr tracer counterparts
we use the combination of the guide rna
and the cas9
protein in airaid crispr knockout
screens
which i will introduce to you now
an arid screen is a
well by well approach where each
individual well contains a different
gene
perturbation here is a workflow depicted
for a hub for human primary t cells as
an example
the cells receive in a one shot
electroporation
guide rna and cas9 protein and
each well will contain cells with a
different
knockout
the essay setup can be very functional
with multiplex readouts allowing a
high resolution analysis of the essay
and it allows to to screen
with various endpoint reads out of
readouts as well
to get really a good set of data
very different functional modalities
and we perform these screens at high
throughput by
using automation platform to assess
various functional readouts
so from the limiting factor here are
always cell numbers but there are always
ways around how to achieve them
and from one error screen you can get a
very good insight into the function
of a particular guide rna
library set
we have so far so far i have shown for
every screen the t-cells and we have so
far developed editing capabilities
in lymphatic and in mild itself it's
also possible to do that in mild
cells and various different lymphocyte
subtypes editing
data is very robust and can be seen
not only at the dna level by t7 essays
but also as loss of surface protein
expression
by flow cytometry
in t cells gene editing can be also
performed in
unstimulated t-cells not only stimulated
cells in blue are the unstimulated cells
in yellow
the stimulated cells and
cells in the top panel receive the
non-targeting guide by cells in the
lower panel received
cd3 guide rna and you can nicely see
in the histogram that cd3 expression is
lost in cells treated with the cd3 guide
rna
in addition this had functional
implications
not only on a protein level detected by
facts but also
on a functional level for proliferation
indifferent gamma secretion and cd25
expression
gene editing for with unstimulated t
cells for instance offers the
possibility
to gene edit also naive t cells which
will then
uh allow to be used to perform
polarization studies
into various different t cell subsets
the story for b cells is slightly
different here
so while it's possible to gene edit
unstimulated and stimulated t-cells this
might be not necessarily
the case for all immune cell types
here we knocked out cd20
and after three days we could see a down
regulation in stimulated
b cells in but this was not the case in
unstimulated
cells so
the successful editing of immune cells
depends
on its activation state and may not work
equally equally well for each subtype
so it really requires extensive
optimization and testing
depending on the cell subtype you want
to use
but once set up it can be
very rewarding so like for instance
here and here an every screen of b reg
cells was used to identify
targets involved in il-10 secretion
a library of 15 genes was chosen
and as a positive control served the
il-10
so you can see it as the very first bar
which is basically not present because
it's knocked out
and this is exactly what we were after
the
knockdown of il-10 so to knock down
il-10 itself was a good control
and several other genes were also
identified
which had an impact on the l10
production either in a positive or
negative way
this screen can be taken to the next
level
by gene edits by using gene edited cells
with other immune cells so in a
co-culture setup
for more physiological in vitro modeling
and here gene edited b-rex cells
were co-cultured with cd
with with other t cells with three to
three positive t cells
and the pde ligand and the
uh il-21 receptor were
knocked out and then these
b-reg cells with that particular
knockout were then
co-cultured with cell trace labeled cd3
cells
interesting interestingly the b-reg
suppression
of t-cell proliferation was suppressed
when il-21 receptor was knocked out
indicating that the l-21 receptor
is plays an important role in the
suppression
in the suppressive ability of b-rex
cells
so horizons essays crispr screening
platform
as just shown is amendable to a diverse
array of functional assays such as
we have just listed a few here immune
cell polarization t cell activation
t cell proliferation and exhaustion
mixed lymphocyte reactions
t-cell mediated tumor cell lyses
antibody dependent cell mediated
cytotoxicity
antibody dependent cell mediated
phagocytosis
t-reg and b-reg suppression essays mdsc
suppression essays
and all of these assays they are
automated
and can be easily scaled up for
high-throughput screening in addition we
have a great history also
in bespoke essay development so if
something is not listed here
um it doesn't mean that it's not
possible and
so it all can be established and can be
customized as well
so far we have talked about an arid
crisper screening
but there's also the pulled crisper
knockout screening
pool crystal screening involves
transduction of cells while the array
screening is transfection of cells
and pooled screening measures the
impact of modulation of all genes of
interest
simultaneously in a single population so
different from the
welterwell approach in the airaid
screening
so let's go into more detail and
have a look at the workflow of such a
pooled crisper knockout screen in
primary human t cells for poor screening
a library of guide rnas is
used in form of a plenty
of lentiviral particles the guide rnas
serve two purposes here first
they will guide the cas9 nucleus to the
genomic location
for cutting as mentioned before and
secondly
they will serve as a bar code to tag the
cells which is
later important when it comes to data
analysis
in a one-step protocol these guide rnas
are cloned into lentiviral backbones
aiming for one individual guide per
lentiviral particles then this
lentiguide library
is introduced into stimulated t cells by
transduction aiming again for one guide
per t-cell
any untransduced cells are removed by
antitrodic selection
cas9 is introduced into the cell via
electroporation
and then drives the editing we end up
with a diverse pool of t-cells carrying
different gene knockouts
it is important to know that we
optimized each of these steps
to keep an excellent balance between
deduction
transfection efficiency and cell
viability because there are many
different steps involved in this
and this outlined approach is different
from
our one vector paradigm we deploy in
tumor cells and that is because we and
others globally observe that cas9 when
introduced by
a lengthy approach does not readily
integrate
um result does not readily integrate
when
when when transduced in primary t
cells and this leads to a poor editing
efficiency
we are developing approaches overcoming
this um
but in the meantime we are very pleased
with our success utilizing this two-step
lenti-mrna system
next this pool of edited cells can be
used to set up
a screening experiment of choice here
the cells are split out
into a control and an experimental
condition
the experimental condition is treated
with
a drug to identify genes that impact
resistance or sensitivity and over time
the composition of t of the t cell pool
will change and differ in the control
and experimental group samples are
collected
and prepared for next generation
sequencing
next generation sequencing will help to
to will help us to do the following so
first
to count the guides which will inform us
about the abundance of each individual
guide
and secondly to link each guide sequence
to the gene it targets
by this we know exactly how many cells
of a particular gene knockout were
present
at the time of pellet collection
to make it less abstract let's have a
look
at a more concrete example
um here in
um here we look at an example for drug
gene interaction in a pilot study we
conducted
the library contained
around 500 genes mostly
in the metabolic pathway
and each of these genes were
individually targeted by a
by around 10 bytes allowing us to
evaluate
reproducibility by redundancy we also
included just
over 2 000 controls to look at
some of the fundamental properties of
crispr editing
and as a drug we use tranformin
an electron chain inhibitor that
inhibits t-cell proliferation
and whose inhibitory effect is
reversed in presence of pyruvate
we intended to identify
genes that make t-cells more sensitive
to fenforming treatment we obtained
next generation data with excellent
overall response rate
from control gene groups
and with this encouraging data we
data said we we proceeded to
hit calling
we identified one very prominent gene
hit and a series of other additional
hits
so one hit i can share with you is got
one and
this hit of got one means that if god
one
is lost by by t cells
those cells become more sensitive to the
electron chain
inhibitor phenfomine
and god1 was not only identified
by us as a sensitizing factor
to fenformin but also by the sabatini
group
while we performed a crispr knockout
screen in t-cells the sabatini lab
performed a crispr knockout in jerked
cells
and identified got one as the only hit
out of three thousand metabolic genes
we not only reproduce data obtained by
another research group
in jerk itself but also we identified
new targets for example our top hit here
that haven't been discovered previously
in jericho cells so this data set
demonstrates nicely the strength of our
crispr cas9
screening platform in t cells
we often get asked about donor
variability
and donor variability can be often seen
across
the whole data sets which is to be
expected
and here donor 2 demonstrated
the least robust hit id but even though
donor 2 was
a little weak it did not detract from
our ability to
perform hit calling and actually still
improve the overall data set
however a cleaner dataset can be
presented by
combining donors as as replicas
and heads were robustly discovered
in two out of three donors
there are several applications for cool
for pooled crisper screening
for instance a whole genome crisper
knockout screen in t-cells
can identify resistant genes to
t cell exhaustion
genetically cells can be exposed to an
exhaustion protocol and cultured in
presence
of tumor cells depending on the knockout
cells will
proliferate differently any effect on
proliferation or survival will manifest
itself by an increase or decrease in
guide rna counts
in addition each guide sequence is
linked to the gene it targets
that way we can screen the whole genome
in a single experiment
for genes that promote exhaustion like
in the yellow population or eliminate
the exhaustion like the green population
if we don't want to rely purely
on a proliferation survival readout we
can combine the pool screening to
a fax sword for a particular biomarker
as you see the screening cascade
is not rigid in fact we have several
pluck and play options to obtain
a very exciting data set
in addition there are multiple options
to monitor the phenotype
of the genetically engineered cells so
for instance
we can perform combinational drug
screens of genetically put up
t cells and other treatment modalities
to elaborate on strategies to
maximize synergism
more physiological more physiological
modeling would be possible by making use
of our 3d oncosign platform to study
tumor penetration and homing
in order to gain a better understanding
of
tumor antigen escape or to rationalize
patient stratification we can make use
of
our crispr ai platform for
tumor cells crispr a
upregulates genes while crispr eye
represses genes
this is a nice tool to fine-tune
gene expression up and down
and we can shed light into the mechanism
by which each
per perturbation mediates
its effect we achieve this by using 10x
genomics
single cell rna-seq technology and this
technology
analyzes transcriptomes on a
cell by cell basis through microfluidic
partitioning
by capturing and barcoding single cells
to obtain
ngs cdna library
finally we come to the base editing
the next generation gene editing systems
such as space editing
have applications for instance in
development
of cell and gene therapies
and horizon is very proud to have
acquired an exclusive license for base
editing
for therapeutic and services use from
the radkus university
and we can sub-license this technology
to
interested parties to move cell therapy
and gene therapy
forward
gene modulation techniques are an
excellent tool
for the systemic dissection of complex
processes
and it can contribute to almost the
entire tract development process
to advance therapeutics
so horizon is offering several different
services and products to support
this pathway and to support the drug
discovery
and the therapy in advancing
therapeutics
and
we wish you all the best for your
research
and we thank you for your attention
and thank you dr brook locker walder for
your
presentation and we will now start
the live q a session of the webinar a
quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far
left of your presentation window labeled
ask a question
and click the send button our presenter
will answer as many questions as
time permits so let's take a look at our
questions
coming in we have quite a few questions
from our audience already
dr bruck locker walder how is cell
viability of human primary t cells
affected by the electoral portration
so um the cell viability is of course
always an issue so it's it's a good
point because
the actual essay is only as good as
the viability of the cells as well
so we routinely assess cell viability
with live dead cell stains by fax
analysis
there's also the possibility to assess
cell viability
in form of self hydrocloak which we also
sometimes do
and in a pool screen
cells will undergo puromycin selection
so
naturally cells without integrated
poromycin cassettes
they will die and after poromycin
selection cells are electroporated
with cas9m mrna which
and and as i mentioned before in the
presentation so
we we have optimized this process to
really balance transactions transaction
efficiency and
viability and cell viability and we
achieve
very good results and with
within a functional essay and with cell
viability and likewise
it is for the air raid screening overall
cell
viability for all immune cell types
tested
so far is acceptable to go ahead with a
functional essay and we receive
very good results with our functional
essays
thank you for that and how many t-cells
are required for a
pulled crisper knockout screen
this is very much this very much depends
on the guide
rna library size if
we take for instance a library covering
the whole genome
then we have to consider several things
so we have to consider
how many genes are in our library the
whole genome has 20 000 genes
then how many guides do we use per gene
for instance if we decide we want to use
four guides per gene
um let's say we use four guys per gene
then
we aim for a coverage of 300 and an moi
of 0.3 this would require us
to use about a little bit more than
70 million cells and if we
think then of the cell population we
want to use for instance cd8 cells which
are about 8 in
peripheral blood we would require about
900 million cells
which we can obtain easily from a
leukocyte cone
and we must not forget that for instance
for t
cells t cells they can be activated they
can be expanded and they
are anyway activated for the full
screening because it's a transduction
protocol
and there are always ways to expand cell
numbers
in a clever way
thank you so much dr ruck locker walder
and thank you to our audience
members for these great questions coming
in
our next question how many jeans can you
test
in a raid crisper knockout scream with
primary human
immune cells so
this is very similar to to the pool
screen it also
depends again on the
library so how many genes
do i want to knock out in a particular
screen and it depends again
also on the cell type so what is the
population
of my peripheral of my immune cell type
in the peripheral blood
and also to which blood prep
perhaps do i have access to so
when we use as when we use peripheral
plaque
source leukocyte cones for instance
then um we intend to set up our and we
intend to set up our
essays in triplicates then we can for
instance screen
500 genes in stimulated cd8 cells or
let's say thousand genes
in stimulated cd4 cells in
using b cells or naive t cells we're a
little bit
more limited because they are
rare in peripheral blood and hence
we can screen about 50 genes from a
donor
but as i mentioned before there are
various ways
how we can increase cell numbers either
by
expanding cells by increasing
donor numbers using different flat preps
for instance we can use looker packs
which contain
more pbmcs or in case of mild sales we
can also pool donors
and thank you for that how many donors
should be
should should be considered to overcome
donor variation
we we usually recommend at least three
donors
it depends very much on the essay
for instance um
we we see very little domino variability
in functional essays with smile itself
but a high degree of donor ability in mk
cells
so donor variability is
is unavoidable and but it's not
necessarily
something unfavorable and
despite all all the efforts
and for donors to donor to eliminate
donor donor
variability it's not really neces it's
not really possible
and donor variations are due to age
sex ethnicity infection history
and genetics and the donors
are usually completely randomized to
provide in vitro data as
physiological representative as possible
to human in vivo systems so therefore
it is not necessarily something
unfavorable because it really will
provide
a good insight how a possible
response and from donors across the
population would look like
thank you and we have time for one more
question
our next question from an audience
member asks
what are your controls to assess
transaction efficiency in a raid
screening
it's a very good question because
controls are very important
and especially in in a big area screen
where it's not possible
to really assess every single well
for transduction efficiency so
we rather use several different
controls which will inform us about the
efficiency of knockouts across
the entire library and we use either
essential genes or lethal guide rna
mixes that provide us with a viability
readout about
cell transduct transfection efficiency
and the more cells are dead
after they have received essential
after we have knocked out an essential
gene or they have received the lethal
guide rna mix
the better the transduction efficiency
so this is one control
or we also use a non-targeting control
and a rosa 26 guide while the
non-targeting control
is not cutting um and hence does not
induce
dna damage the rosa 26
is targeting the human homologous of
frozen 26
and induces cutting but without
a functional impact so we can then
disturb the control of the dna
damage and the repair and as a positive
control we use
a target that is prominently and
constitutively expressed by immune cells
of interest vents by usually for
instance for t cells it would be cd3
cells
as it is part of the t cell receptor
complex
and these controls are usually
represented several times in an essay
and they are monitored
across donors plates and replicas so we
have at the end a very good data set
where we can then assess
as a performance and where we have extra
plots
just assessing the lc performance across
the board
dr brook walker walder thank you very
much for your presentation today and for
your important research
before i go i want to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting
questions and i'd also like to thank
our sponsor horizon discovery
and before we go i'd also like to remind
you
that this webcast can be viewed on
demand
and we will alert you via email when
it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
this email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care and bye